let's get going beginning this news are
in the United States where figures just
out paint a devastating picture of the
state of the economy in just five weeks
all of the jobs created since the end of
the 2009 recession have been wiped out
here are the numbers last week another
4.4 million Americans filed for
unemployment benefits
that's fewer than the week before when
more than 5.3 million registered for
jobless support but the speed of the
rise in those figures is unprecedented
in all more than 26 million Americans
have now applied for unemployment
benefits since the end of March that was
when President Donald Trump made the
first of his kovat 19 outbreak
declarations let's talk now to our White
House correspondent Kimberly halket
joining us from Washington so staggering
staggering fingers configures Kimberly
yeah they are staggering but not
unexpected we know that for some time
there is estimated to be at least 46
million Americans that instantly became
unemployed as a result of these stay at
home orders in the United States and so
the reason that we see these significant
climbs week after week is that this is
the unemployment insurance offices
across the country processing these
claims as quickly as they can but not
able to do it all at once so what we
know is that many Americans had
struggled to get through on the websites
these are antiquated systems that just
aren't just designed for this kind of
demand and so as a result we know that
these numbers will continue to climb for
a number of weeks but this Peter is a
reason why this US president is so eager
to reopen the economy the numbers are
staggering as you point out and they hit
across all sectors especially hard-hit
is the hospitality industry restaurants
and hotels but also construction so the
US president had been the jobs president
he brought on a platform as he
campaigned in 2016-2017 the promise to
create jobs and
the most part he delivered it but all of
those games have evaporated and this is
a president trying to run for
re-election so this is why you hear the
tone from the US president very eager to
reopen this economy but again these
numbers make that especially challenging
when it comes to the election in
November when it comes to the voters I
guess what we're seeing here as well is
a direct impact on people who did not
have any fiscal saving safety net they
don't have savings they've got to hit
the mortgage they've got to hit the car
payments and if they're up queer street
and they don't have any money for four
weeks they're financially in very very
hot water yeah and you'll remember that
enormous rescue package that came out of
the US Congress that two trillion dollar
package that allowed for many Americans
to get a check of roughly twelve hundred
US dollars I can tell you in major
cities like Washington DC Chicago Los
Angeles that doesn't go very far that
barely pays the rent for a very small
sized single room apartment so this is
hardly going to be adequate for even
just a single person to try and manage
not just for four weeks but potentially
for four months because what we're being
told is that many of these jobs aren't
coming back and that is what many
Americans are starting to come to grips
with Peter I can tell you the lineups
for the food banks here are historic in
terms of the need that is out there
there is a tremendous amount of
suffering and it's only going to
continue still this president is trying
very hard to cheerlead he is saying that
there is a grand reopening of states
soon that will be happening he says
roughly 20 percent or rather 20 states
40 percent of the population but we know
this is going to be a very measured
reopening in fact there even is conflict
right now between the state of Georgia
and the US president that this governor
may be opening a little bit too soon and
may be in conflict with some of the
federal guidance that calls for a very
phased opening but very quickly Peter I
can tell you there is an effort on
Capitol Hill to try and bring about even
more help for the states that is coming
in the form of a legislative package
that has already passed the Senate now
has to go through the House of
Representatives Singh
difficut because this will allow small
businesses to keep some of those
employees on their payroll the first
rule out of this very successful in the
neighborhood of three hundred and fifty
billion dollars but it ran out so now
they're looking for more money they've
got the money it's just a matter now
voting on it the president signing it
into law and all significant in that
package will be money for national
testing something that will also allow
workers to begin to go back to work when
it comes to making sure people have
enough money literally to live though
Kimberly is there more pressure coming
at this administration from people like
Boeing we're reporting on that today
they're just about to lose forever we
assume ten percent of their plane
building division and they're gonna go
to the Trump administrations they look
you've got to give us a bailout
that's not loose change in somebody's
back pocket that's going to be a
multi-million multi-billion dollar
request on their part yeah and right now
sort of the underlying tone in
Washington that's not being talked about
is how is the United States paying for
all of this we've seen some very
creative arrangements that are taking
place the Federal Reserve that typically
monitors and sort of controls interest
rates and monetary policy now doing
these unusual type of loans that we
don't normally see in Washington's
become very creative for the sheer
amount of money that it's handing out
you've got to remember this is a country
with an enormous double-digit deficit
this is what nobody's talking about
right now is this they continue to try
and prop up this economy in election
years they continue to try and help
alleviate the real and genuine suffering
that exists in this country there's no
discussion about how we are going to pay
all of this back we already knew that
this debt that was accumulated in the
United States was going to be passed on
for generations
this is Republicans typically our fiscal
conservatives that's not the
conversation that's being had right now
in Washington and again we have to be
cognizant of the fact this is an
election year this is a US president
that says he wants to rebuild the
economy a second
time but given these enormous payouts
that are happening not just for ordinary
individuals but the corporations as you
point out it seems to enormous ly hard
to try and balance the books not just
before this election but for the
foreseeable future
Kimberly thanks very much I stole now to
Aaron's to Jonah he's a labor economist
and professor at the University of
Minnesota he has advised both the Trump
and Obama administrations Aaron's the
Jonah welcome to the NewsHour here on
al-jazeera what does this tell us about
the state of the US economy well it's an
unprecedented fall and employment and I
really rap at the pace it means that you
know we're dealing with the public
health challenge as best we can and
given the limited tools we have but we
really need to deal with the public
health threat head-on and how will they
do that I think we need one of three
things we need a vaccine we need a
widespread treatment that works we don't
have either of those things technically
right now technologically proven the
third thing is white and scale testing
which has been proven feasible in other
places but we haven't done it here and
you know that allows you to relax the
broad quarantines and allows you to tell
apart who's contagious and sick and make
sure they get care from people who are
well and can work and more safely and
you know enables a lot of public health
strategies like contact tracing and
other other mechanisms so we need to
throw every productive resource we have
at that okay and we're talking about the
economy as well just to interrupt your
enjoy now we're talking about the
economy as well clearly what does this
administration do now to make sure that
when these figures are revisited in say
two or four weeks 26 million unemployed
hasn't turned into being 30 million
unemployed or 35 million unemployed I'm
telling you there's no shortcut around
the public health challenge there's no
way to get around it
other than to develop public health
strategies that can preserve lives while
allowing people to get along with their
regular economic activity you can try to
take a shortcut and hurry people back to
work without being able to tell who's
contagious and who's not but it'll
provoke a worse health crisis and it
works
economic crisis if you were advising we
can do pardon me for interrupting you
but if you were advising the people in
the White House today would you be
saying to them the states the individual
states must not reopen because if you
send people back to work to be able to
say you've got them in a job you might
end up with that second coming flu
season spike of the flu and the
coronavirus blended into that as well
yeah I think that is a real risk and
that needs to be managed with eyes wide
open and you know clear sense of the
cost and benefits so you know there's
plenty of people who are working right
now who are doing essential jobs like
health care and groceries and Public
Safety and they are taking additional
risks than they used to and you know
we're all grateful for that so it's a
question of it's not a light switch it's
a question of being smart and you know
balancing the risks and benefits of work
but what I would advise them is to
invest every productive resource you can
in the meeting the public health
challenge talk to the public health
experts and give them everything they
need to be successful and at the same
time I think the important question is
how do we support families and small
businesses through this time when we're
asking them and we need them to stop
doing their usual ways of supporting
themselves and give up that income and
we need to find alternative ways to
support them so that they don't
deteriorate economically and health-wise
and
mental health so they're ready to come
back when the time comes that that can
be done safely okay Aaron so Jonah thank
you very much